Nur wenige Mauerreste gibt es noch in Berlin
– etwa die von Künstlern bemalten Teile
an der Eastside Gallery.
An Schrecken der Grenze erinnert
die Gedenkstätte „Berliner Mauer“.
Vielerorts markieren nur noch Pflastersteine
den Verlauf der innerstädtischen Grenze.
Dabei interessiert gerade dieses
Kapitel viele Berlin-Touristen.
Man müsste mehr davon sehen, gerade
weil das so ein historischer Ort ist.
Die Mauerteile finde ich gut,
aber man hätte hier
die geschichtliche Bedeutung mehr
wertschätzen sollen.
Genau darum geht es in dem 2012
eröffneten „Mauerpanorama“.
Hier sollen Besucher das Leben in der
ehemals geteilten Stadt nachempfinden.
Sie tauchen ein in das Berlin
der 1980er Jahre.
An einem grauen Novembertag
werfen sie einen Blick von Westberlin aus
hinüber in den Osten.
Musik, vermischt mit Tonaufnahmen
aus der damaligen Zeit,
soll das Erlebnis verstärken.
Ich hab noch ne Gänsehaut.
Also es ist … so konnte man sich
das gar nicht vorstellen.
Was ich jetzt gesehen habe – ich meine,
man kennt die Bilder durchs Fernsehen,
aber das hier, man ist so mitten drin,
man ist dabei. Also ich muss sagen:
Ganz faszinierend.
Es war sehr beeindruckend.
Auch den geschichtlichen Hintergrund,
man spürt ihn doch im Raum.
Dreieinhalb Jahre hat der
persischstämmige Künstler Yadegar Asisi
an dem Panoramabild gearbeitet.
Wir stehen fünf Meter von der
Berliner Mauer entfernt
und gucken über die Berliner Mauer
von Westen in Richtung Osten
und sehen, dass Menschen neben dieser
Mauer leben wie sie überall leben,
also ohne zu begreifen, dass sie neben
der Berliner Mauer,
oder ohne zu registrieren, dass sie neben
der Berliner Mauer leben.
Yadegar Asisi bildet den Alltag im
Schatten der Mauer ab.
Atmosphärische Dichte ist ihm wichtiger
als dokumentarische Treue.
Sein Blick ist der eines Zeitzeugen,
denn er hat selbst jahrelang in
dem Teil von Berlin gelebt,
den er in seinem Panorama inszeniert.
Fast alles, was Sie hier sehen,
habe ich erlebt,
und deswegen musste
ich nicht recherchieren.
Meine Recherche war mein Gehirn.
Yadegar Asisi kam in Wien zur Welt
und wuchs in der DDR auf.
1978 wurde er nach Westberlin abgeschoben
und wohnte nahe der Grenze.
Für ihn war die Betonmauer
ein Teil seines Alltags.
Am Computer setzt er seine Welt von
damals neu zusammen
– aus Zeichnungen und unzähligen Fotos,
die er mit Statisten aufgenommen hat.
Diese Patina dieser Zeit auch zu kreieren,
das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Dann wirklich Accessoires auch
zu finden aus der Zeit,
dass diese Zeit wieder auflebt.
Das geht eben von der verfallenen
Fassade
bis zum Kaugummiautomaten
der damaligen Zeit.
Man muss dann schon sehr
konsequent sein.
Für das 15 Meter hohe und 60 Meter
breite Rundbild wurde eigens
eine Rotunde mit einem
Besucherturm gebaut.
Zwanzig Stoffbahnen wurden
bedruckt und zusammengetackert.
Der logistische und finanzielle
Aufwand ist erheblich.
Die Problematik beim Panorama ist,
dass einfach alles riesig ist
sofort ins Geld geht und man eigentlich
nicht daran glaubt,
dass so was für einen einzelnen
Künstler überhaupt machbar ist.
Mit dem Panorama „Die Mauer“ widmet
er sich erstmals
einem Thema der Zeitgeschichte.
Das Riesenrundbild zeigt, wie banal
alltäglich und subtil grausam
zugleich die Normalität der
geteilten Stadt war.
Die Leute werden hier rausgehen
und werden sagen:
„Ich habe an der Berliner
Mauer gestanden“.
Es wird viel realer als die Erinnerung,
so real wie es jetzt hier ist.
Vielleicht werden sie auch ein paar
Gedanken mehr haben
und würden sagen: „Wie würde ich mich
eigentlich arrangieren,
wenn so was mit mir passieren würde?“
Oder sie gehen nach
Hause und sagen:
„Ich arrangiere mich doch auch in
meinem Leben, in meinem Beruf,
in meinem Privatleben und so weiter.“
Ich glaube, das lässt viele Fragen zu,
aber vielleicht auch ein paar Antworten.
Bei denen, die das geteilte Berlin erlebt
haben, weckt das Panorama Erinnerungen.
Und Touristen vermittelt es einen Eindruck
vom Leben an der Mauer.